Нас попросили не називати ані вулицю
на якій вона живе
ані навіть район Санкт-Петербурга
Її життя - в небезпеці.
Адже Людмилі Савчук два роки тому вдалося
потрапити у середовище так званих інтернет-тролів
Журналістка працювала в російській
"Агенції інтернет-досліджень"
Це офіційна назва "фабрики тролів" у Санкт-Петербурзі
проти керівництва якої
нині позиваються США
Коли зазвичай людина приходить на фабрику
у неї вже висить готове завдання на комп’ютері,
в неї є список тем, за яким тролі працюють щодня
Поливати брудом США – це одна з найважливіших тем
у будь-який час
Два роки тому ми вже намагалися вийти на контакт
з працівниками "фабрики тролів"
що прихована за цим фасадом у Санкт-Петербурзі
Безрезультатно
Через викриття Людмили Савчук "фабрика тролів" на вулиці Савушкіна стала відомою
Завдяки цьому відео
яке нам надав один з колишніх співробітників "фабрики тролів"
ми можемо зазирнути всередину
За словами Людмили Савчук
тоді там працювали понад тисячу співробітників
їхня робота оплачувалася вище, ніж в середньому в Росії
І це не єдина "фабрика тролів" в країні
Нині ніхто не знає
наскільки вони насправді вплинули на вибори у США, на кожну людину
наскільки змінилися результати під впливом російського втручання
Те, що вплив був, це поза сумнівом
Навіть якщо одна людина на замовлення англійською мовою
для американської публіки написала бодай один пост
це вже спроба впливу
На думку Людмили Савчук, позов США проти керівництва "фабрики тролів"
це символічний сигнал для багатьох
Звісно, їх було не тринадцять. І навіть не сто тридцять
Це величезна робота проводилася
і я впевнена, що вона досі триває
І я так розумію, що ці люди, які зараз в списку
це ті, щодо яких зібрали достатньо доказів для обвинувачення
Я сподіваюсь, що ці викриття триватимуть
адже людей там працює дуже багато - спільно з російською пропагандою
Тому сподіваюсь, що доказів зберуть більше і список розширять
Поки що ж фейкові новини, зроблені в Росії
і далі розлітатимуться світом
І не лише із Санкт-Петербурга